- Autonomous driving is a
big technological challenge.
Probably the biggest of our generation.
- [Narrator] This is a Tesla.
It comes with a feature
known as autopilot.
And Elon Musk says in the future,
it'll have a feature called.
- Full self-driving.
- [Narrator] Several other
cars being sold today
also come with assisted driving technology
which still requires
someone behind the wheel.
But new vehicles that won't
have anyone in the driver's seat
are getting closer to production.
Startups Waymo, Cruise,
TuSimple, and Aurora,
are already testing driverless tech
on some public roads across America.
- It's gonna move quickly.
We'll start to see this
move from prototypes
to actually scaling products (indistinct).
- We see us becoming
fully driverless in 2024.
- [Narrator] As they
invest billions in R&D
and sign multi-billion dollar deals,
their valuations have soared
and TuSimple has gone public.
They're pitching a future where
people won't even own cars.
- Younger generations won't
even think about owning a car.
- [Narrator] And some
jobs will no longer exist.
- We fundamentally believe
that every trucker will be able
to retire as a trucker.
- [Narrator] But first of all,
they need to convince governments
and the public that
their technology is safe.
- You're limiting your potential
if consumers are not comfortable
getting into your vehicle
and taking a ride.
- [Narrator] So could
these startups make driving
a thing of the past?
Tesla has been working
on making its vehicles
autonomous since around 2016
and said it planned to
have self-driving cars
on the road by 2020.
- And sometimes I'm not on time.
But I get it done.
- [Narrator] For now,
experts say these cars
have what they call level two autonomy.
- It is a level two system
where they're saying
that the driver has to be there,
they have to pay attention.
They're counting on them.
- [Narrator] What does that mean?
Well, it's a scale used by auto engineers
and it starts at zero.
- Which means, you know,
kind of a 1950s car
with no automation at all.
- [Narrator] And goes up to level five.
- [Tekedra] Basically when
the car can do everything,
anywhere.
- You can drop it off in Afghanistan today
and it will be able to operate
without maps by itself.
- [Narrator] Instead of releasing vehicles
and working towards autonomy,
these top startups want
to roll them out directly
at level four autonomy.
Which is where the car
doesn't need a driver
as long as it's preloaded with information
about its surroundings
like maps and directions.
- And we just simply think
level four is the goal
for any domain.
- [Narrator] Some companies
in the US and Asia
like Baidu AutoX and Didi,
say they've reached level
four in some vehicles
though none have rolled
them out at commercial scale
but some are getting close.
Waymo and Cruise have
piloted a fleet of robotaxis
in some ring-fenced areas around the US.
Think ride-hailing without the driver.
Like this, the Waymo One.
- We're the only company
that has a fully autonomous
ride-hailing service
available to the public today
in the Phoenix metro area.
- [Narrator] In late 2020,
Waymo began removing support drivers
from its vehicles after its cars racked up
some 20 million miles on public roads,
gathering troves of
data for its algorithms.
- The car shows up completely empty.
They take a ride from point A to point B.
That's one of the ways you make this real,
is you launch a service in the city
and you see if customers will
actually adopt the service
and use it.
- [Narrator] Waymo started
as a Google project in 2009,
and now has a $30 billion
valuation and Alphabet,
Google's parent, as a
majority shareholder.
Cruise has roughly the
same valuation as Waymo
and is owned by GM.
With whom it has built an
autonomous vehicle from scratch.
It has accrued fewer miles
than Waymo, some two million,
in it's tests in San Francisco.
- Miles driven absolutely matters
because ultimately the goal
is to put this technology
on public roads,
interacting with other
human-driven vehicles.
So you do need that experience
at some point to say,
yes, this is not only safe,
but it's actually viable.
- [Narrator] Cruise
recently got permission
to remove the support driver
but it's yet to carry paying passengers.
It plans to begin
production of this vehicle,
the Origin, in 2023.
We spoke with company
representatives over the phone,
who said GM's backing
is a strategic advantage
but it's not just cars,
startups are also eyeing trucks.
- The trucking industry
is a massive industry.
It's $4 trillion globally,
800 billion dollars in the US alone.
- [Narrator] That's the market Aurora
and TuSimple are betting on.
Aurora which has received
investment from Uber
says it has a handful of test vehicles out
on public roads in the US.
TuSimple has around 60
autonomous trucks circulating
on highways in the Southwest
with support drivers.
It was the first driverless
company in the US
to go public, getting a
roughly $8.5 billion valuation.
- In the US alone, 60,000
driver shortages this year
that will increase to
about 160,000 by 2028
based on latest numbers.
So it's a very real problem.
- We don't intend to ever
build a car or build a truck.
We work with great companies
like Paccar and Volvo
and Toyota, and integrate our
technology to their vehicles.
- I think consumer goods
can provide, you know,
an easier path.
You're already kind of
simplifying the situations
that you would have to deal with.
If you're driving the same pathway often,
you're not gonna have pedestrians
and cyclists, you know,
interacting with traffic.
- [Narrator] But their tech needs
to overcome some big challenges
before it can be widely adopted.
- And the more we discover
about the challenges,
the more we learn about how
long this is gonna take.
And so I think you saw all of industry
start to reset expectations.
- [Narrator] Waymo and others
had previously said 2020
was the year that robotaxis
would become commonplace
across the US but the coronavirus pandemic
and technical hurdles
have led to forecasts being pushed back.
One issue, these vehicles
still don't work well at night
or in bad weather.
- It's not a coincidence that
you see companies testing
in fair weather places first.
- When you think about the barriers,
it's really engineering barriers.
It's time, it takes capital,
but we'll get there.
- [Narrator] But those
are not the only barriers.
- A Honda Civic right there
colliding with the Waymo van.
We're being told it was not
at fault in this accident.
- [Narrator] The industry has
to address safety concerns.
As autonomous cars have been involved
in a number of accidents in recent years.
After a fatal crash in 2018,
where a car's built in automatic
emergency braking system
was disabled, Uber had to stop
testing autonomous vehicles
in Arizona.
It continued tests in other cities
before selling its unprofitable
self-driving car unit
to Aurora at the end of 2020.
All players in this industry know
that they have to deal
with a lot of skepticism.
- There's this suggestion
that the technology
is presenting new risk or first risk.
The reality is though roads have risk.
- So it's not possible to
make anything 100% safe,
whether it's a toothbrush or an airliner.
And so we try to make these systems
really safe.
- [Narrator] A recent study found
that even if autonomous
vehicles cause accidents
at half the rate of human drivers,
only 37% of Americans would opt in.
- We've got more forgiveness,
we've got more understanding
if that happens or is caused
by another human driver.
I don't think we have that
same compassion for a robot
that might produce the same result.
- [Narrator] To show that
self-driving vehicles
because very few accidents,
Waymo started disclosing
all of its crashes
and near misses in Arizona,
a total of 47 episodes over 2019 and 2020.
- Because we thought
it was really important
to start to demonstrate
that you insert a fully autonomous
vehicle into an ecosystem
and there is still human
error around the vehicle.
- Sure, we've got disengagements,
we've got miles driven,
we've got the number of crashes
and we can relate that to human drivers,
but that doesn't necessarily
make it much easier
to kind of say, this is
safe, safer, or safe enough.
So just being able to
quantify these things
I think it's still a
challenge for the industry.
(gentle music)